WASHINGTON NEXT UP, AND REXALL
PLACE ON THURSDAY DMNIGHT.
>> Craig: THEY ARE A LITTLE
BANGED UP ARE THE OILERS.
>> Joe: BYFUGLIEN HAS THE
REBOUND WITH THAT ALL-RED STICK.
LADD TURNS IT ON TOP.
OVECHKIN IS OH AWAY.
IN SOLO, AND HE SCORES!
>> Craig: REAL BAD GIVE AWAY
LADD TURNS THE PUCK OVER,
OVECHKIN STREAKS DOWN THE ICE
WITH A LITTLE BIT OF PRESSURE
FROM THE ASSISTANT CAPTAIN, AND
ALEX OVECHKIN, MONEY.
HERE IS THE DEKE.
HERE IS THE BAD PASS COMING
ACROSS.
AND HERE HE COMES, PAVELEC TRIES
TO GUESS WHAT ALEX WAS GOING TO
DO HERE, JOE, AND HE WAS CAUGHT
LEAGUE-LEADING TOTALS IN SHOTS
AND OVERALL TALLIES.
IT'S A MISDRAW.
THEY'LL DO IT AGAIN.
AND THEY'LL DO IT WITHOUT
BACKSTROM.
HE IS GOING TO BE EXCUSED FROM
THE DOT.
JOHANSSON WILL TAKE THIS DRAW.
AND WIN IT.
OVECHKIN SCORES!
A BEAUTIFULLY DISGUISED RELEASE
JAND IT'S 3-2.
GOAL I JUST TALKED ABOUT.
THIS IS A HUGE BOOST FOR THE
CAPTAIN.
THERE IS ANOTHER ONE FOR THE
GREAT EIGHT.